The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So what
we've been trying
to do is to develop a
description of properties
of some system,
could be something
like a gas, that includes
both mechanical as well
as thermal properties.
So the first thing
that we decided to do
was to wait until
this system has
properties that do not change.
Further, with the
observation time
that we are assigning
to this system,
and then if it is
a gas we can say,
OK the gas has some
pressure and volume.
In general, we said that we
can characterize the system
through a set of displacements
and the conjugate forces which
are used when we describe
systems that are mechanical.
Work on them is done.
We can say that the work
is Jdx, for example.
OK?
Then we decided that this
mechanical description
was not enough because
systems could exchange heat
and gradually started to build
a more general prescription that
included the exchange of heat.
We saw that, for example,
from the zeroth law,
we could define temperature as
a function of these quantities.
And that we could also, from
the first law define energy.
And in particular that
the change in energy,
which is a function of where
you are in equilibrium.
So once you say that you
have a system in equilibrium
you can say what the values
of the x's and J's are.
You know somehow what
the value of temperature
is, what the value of energy is.
And if you were to
make a change in energy
by some external means
the amount of change
would either come
from mechanical work
that you did on the
system, or the heat
that you supplied to the system.
Now this expression
is the one that you
would like to elevate somehow
and be able to compute energy
as a function of state.
Kind of keeping in
mind what we would
do if there was no heat around.
And we could do things
mechanically, then mechanically
we could in principle build up
the energy function by changing
displacements lightly and
calculating the amount of work
by this formula.
And basically we
emphasized that you
would be able to use
a formula such as this
if you were to make
things sufficiently slowly
so that at each
stage in the process
you can calculate
what Ji is, which
means that at each
stage in the process
you should be in some kind
of an equilibrium state.
OK?
If that was the case, if
you didn't have dQ then
this would be your
energy function
and actually once you had the
energy function you could,
for example, calculate J
as a derivative of energy
with respect to x.
So then you also start
thinking about how many
independent degrees
of freedom do I have.
Do I really need all of the
set of x's and J's to describe
my system in equilibrium.
If additionally once I know the
e, I can derive all of the J's.
So we have to also
come eventually
to grips with how many
independent degrees of freedom
will describe our system.
Now the first step towards
completing this expression
was to find what dQ is.
So we needed another
law of thermodynamics
beyond zeroth law and first
law that somehow related
heat and temperature
to each other.
As we expect that
somehow this expression
will leave you temperature.
And what we used was some
version of the second law.
That was there how heat would
flow from, say, a hot air body
to a cold air body.
And Clausius's theorem would say
that you have only heat flowing
in one particular direction.
Well, we sort of
introduced the idea
of engines, which
are machines that
are used to do work by taking
heat from the heart air body
to the cold air body.
And we could define
an efficiency,
which is work divided by heat
input, which since work is
the difference between these
two we could write as 1 minus Qc
over Qh.
And then we introduced
this special class
of engines, which were
these Carnot engines.
And the idea of this class
was that you could run them
forward and backward.
They were kind of reversible.
The were kind of a analogue
of the frictionless type
of processes that you would use
to construct mechanical energy.
And we found that these engines
were the most efficient.
And so the efficiency
of these engines
was marked only by
the two temperatures.
So we had the functional form
potentially of efficiency
as a function of the two
temperatures involved.
And what we also showed
was that the efficiency
of any random engine
was going to be
less than the efficiency
of the Carnot engine
that is marked by
these two temperatures.
And by putting some
Carnot engines in series,
we saw that the good
way to write this
was something of this form.
I can in principle
remove the one
from the two sides
of this equation
and rearrange it a
little bit into the form
Qh over Th plus minus Qc over
Tc because of this inequality
writing it as less
than or equal to 0.
OK?
What does that tell us?
As it stands, not much.
But then I promised you
at the end of last lecture
then this is an example of
a much more powerful result,
which is the Clausius Theorem.
So let's start with writing
what that theorem is
and how it relates to
a simple expression.
And the theory is that
for any cyclic process
I can, cyclic,
what does it mean?
Is that in the set of
coordinates in principle
that is used to
describe the system,
I will start with the
position that is equilibrium,
so I can put that
point in this state,
but then I make
a transformation.
And ultimately
return to that point.
So the cycle is the
So I carry out a set of steps.
And I haven't indicated
the set of steps
through a connected
continuous curve
in this multi-dimensional
coordinate space
because I don't want
to restrict myself
to processes that are
even in equilibrium.
So I may take a gas
that I have over there,
expand it rapidly, close it
rapidly as long as I wait when
I come back to the
same point that I
have reached my
equilibrium again.
I have done a cyclic process.
Now at each stage of this
cyclic process presumably
the system takes in a
certain amount of heat.
So let's say that
there is a dQ that
goes at this stage
of the process.
So I use s to indicate, say,
stage 0, one, two, three,
four all the way coming back.
So this is just a
numbering process.
The statement of
Clausius's theorem
is that for any cyclic process
if I go out around the cycle,
add up these elements of
heat that are delivered
to this system and I allow
the possibility therefore
that some of the times
these elements dQ
will be negative just as I
did over here by writing this
as minus Qc so
that what the dQ is
what has gone into
whatever this black box is.
So Qh went into this black box.
Qc went out, which means
that minus Qc went in
so I arranged it
in this fashion.
You can see that
the elements of heat
are divided by some temperature.
I generalize that expression
over here by writing it T of S
here.
And the statement of
Clausius's theorem
is that this quantity has the
same sign constraint as here
where I told you that
dQ is heat delivered
to system at
temperature T sub s.
Now this particular thing
requires a certain amount
of thinking about.
Because I told you that your
system is not in equilibrium.
So what is this T
sub S if you have
a system that is
not in equilibrium?
You can't define
its temperature.
However, you can imagine
that whatever machine
was delivering it had sump
particular temperature.
And so that's the
temperature of the device
or whatever is delivering
this heat to the system.
And you would be
justified to say, well,
why is that even useful?
Because certainly if I were to
have exactly the same cycle,
but deliver the heat elements
through a different process
this Ts would be different.
So this is really
also a function
of the method through which I
want to carry out this cycle.
So given that it doesn't sound
like a particularly useful
theorem.
It seems very arbitrary.
So let's first prove it.
The proof is simple.
And then see whether
it's useful or not.
Any questions at this point?
OK.
So how do we go proving it?
We are going to use
these Carnot engines.
So what I will imagine is
that I have some big vat that
is at some, let's
say, for purposes
of, use a high temperature,
a vat of hot water.
And I use this
vat as the process
that provides heat
to this entity.
Exactly what do I mean by that?
I will use a Carnot
engine to take heat.
Let's call it Qh, although its
sign is not that particularly
important.
And convert this
into the heat element
dQs that is delivered here.
So since I'm using s, an
infinitesimal element here,
let me call this dQ.
And let's call it dQ0
because I'm picking it
up from the temperature of T0.
So I have as a result
of this process
a certain amount of work.
All of this corresponds
to the s-th element
through this particular cycle.
So I divide my cycle
to lots of elements.
Each element takes in
this amount of heat
and I use a Carnot engine to
deliver that heat and always
taking the Carnot engine
from the input from T0,
but what it delivers is where
this randomness in temperature
T of S comes about.
Why did I use a Carnot engine?
Because I said that
sometimes this cycle
is going to take in heat.
Sometimes it is going
to give out heat.
So I want to be able to run
this both forward and backwards.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you delivering
the work to the cycle too?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: The work
goes whenever it goes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
And indeed that's the next
step of the argument, which
is what happened to the work?
OK?
So we do this.
At the end of this story I
am back to where I started.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I'm--
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe I
missed something basic,
but I don't understand
why you can't just
define the function dQ not of
s and ignore the Carnot engine.
Just deliver it the key.
What was wrong with
just the blue arrow?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Why can't I just take
heat from here to here?
Because in principle
where I put it
is at a different
temperature when I eventually
go to equilibrium.
And then I would run into
problems of second law,
as to the ability
to transfer heat
from a hotter to colder engine.
So if you like this
intermediate stage,
allows me ultimately two
vary this temperature Ts.
What you say is correct as long
as the T of S is uniformly T0.
It kind of becomes useless.
OK?
All right.
So we enclose our cycle, the
Carnot engine, everything
into a box.
And we see what
this box is doing.
So there is the box.
The box takes in elements of
heat, dQ from the reservoir.
And does elements of work,
dW at different stages.
Now once the cycle
has been completed,
the net result is that I have
extracted an amount of heat,
so this is the net,
extracted heat is
the integral over the
cycle of dQ0 of s.
And converted it to work.
Oh, one other step.
Once I'm using
the Carnot engine,
and I think I
emphasized this, there
is a relationship between
heat and temperature.
It is this
proportionally-- Qh is
proportional to h for
the Carnot engine.
Qc is proportional to Tc.
So there is a proportionality
between the heat that I take
and the heat that I deliver that
is related to the temperatures.
So dQ0 is in fact T0 dQ that
goes into the engine divided
by the temperature at which
it is delivered to the engine.
OK?
Now I know also
something about this
because the second
law of thermodynamics
says that no process is
possible whose soul result
is the conversion
of heat to work.
I can do the opposite.
I can convert work
to heat, but that
means that the integral
here has to be negative.
OK?
Now T0 is just a
positive constant.
So once I divide
through by that I
have gotten the proof of
the statement [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So how
is this is really
going to help with the
definition of T of s
because get theoretically
even your extraction of heat
and your doing the work in
that black box or the opposite
could happen
irreversibly, right?
So you--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --still
have a problem.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So as I have written
it here I would agree.
It looks completely useless.
So let's make it useful.
How am I going to
make it useful?
So let's start some set of
corollaries to this theorem.
For the first thing is we
get rid of this definition
by considering a
reversible transformation.
OK?
So same picture that I was
drawing before with multiple
coordinates.
Start some point and come back.
But now I will draw is
solid curve in this space,
meaning that at each
stage of the process
I will do it sufficiently
slowly so that my system comes
to thermal equilibrium
and I can identify it
as a point in this
generalized phase space.
OK?
So now I have points in this
generalized phase space.
To each point I can therefore
assign the equilibrium
temperature.
That I am at that
stage of the cycle.
OK?
So now I can request
my Carnot engines
to deliver the heat at the
temperature of the system
to be maintaining the whole
system plus the Carnot engines
at thermal equilibrium as
I switch from one cycle
to another cycle.
OK?
So now I have a
relationship that
is pertaining to things
that are in equilibrium.
As long as I follow the
equilibrium temperature
of the system and do
reversible transformations
I have the result that
dQ reversible over Ts
is less than 0.
But the things about-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Could
you explain again
why the path integral
of dQ not over s
is smaller than [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Clausius's theorem says that
if I took heat from a vat
and converted it to useful work
I have violated the second law.
So the sign of the
net amount of heat
that I extracted better
be negative, right?
OK.
So you are not going to
be able to have a vat
and extract energy out of
the lake and run your engine.
It's not allowed.
OK?
Now my path is reversible, which
means that I could go this way,
or I could go the opposite way.
And if I go the
opposite way, what
was the definition
of reversible?
I reverse all of a heat
exchanges inputs and outputs.
OK?
Which means that what I
was calling previously
dQ becomes minus dQ.
So the inequality holds
for both minus or plus,
which means that as long as I
do reversible transformations
I must have the integral
to be equal to 0.
OK?
Good.
So we constructed
in a sense analog
of doing frictionless
ways of doing work
and increasing the
energy of the system.
We have an idea
about reversible ways
and their relationship
to T, well,
one step further I need to go.
Which is that I go
from some point A
to some point B in
my coordinate space.
OK?
I can do it multiple ways.
I can go this way
and then come back.
Reversibly, I can go
this way and come back
one way or the other.
So every way I have
a number of choices.
Essentially what it says
is that I can go from say A
to B, dQ, reversible
over T, over some path,
and the answer is going to
be the same for doing it
along a different path.
Because if I went
along this path
I can close the reversible cycle
either by returning that way
or by going the other way.
So going this way
or going that way,
the result of the integration
along reversible path
should be the same.
And it should be the same
also for any other path
that I take between
these two points.
So it kind of again reminds
us of pushing a particle
up a hill.
And as long as you are
doing things frictionlessly
the amount of work that
you do in this process
does not depend on
how you go there.
It's just the potential
energy difference
between the two points.
So this entity being
independent of the path
implies immediately
that there is
some function like a potential
energy that only depends
on the two end
points and this is
how you would
decline the entropy.
OK?
So what we have
essentially said is
that if I take an
infinitesimal step there's
an infinitesimal amount of heat
that I can do reversibly, that
is related to the change
of the state function
through let's say dS is
dQ reversible over T.
Or vice versa, dQ
[INAUDIBLE] TdS.
OK?
We've done it finally.
We can get our
expression because we
have now the possibility
to go from this point
to this point reversibly using
a reversible transformation.
And calculate the
change in energy.
Now quite generally the change
in energy conservation lay,
it's dW plus dQ.
If I do this reversible
change so that each element
I am in equilibrium.
I know what J is.
The dW is sum over iJidxi.
And I have established
that as long
as I do the reversible
transformations dQ is TdS.
And so we have this formula.
OK?
So I will write that
again because really this
is the most important
relationship
that you need to know
from thermal dynamics.
And we have to put all
kinds of colorful things
around it so you remember.
OK?
Now in particular there is
a very common misconception
which is that results are
relevant to transformations.
And you derive this result for
a reversible transformation.
So this formula is only valid
for reversible transformation.
No.
That's not the case.
It is like saying, I
calculated the potential energy
of pushing something up the hill
through a frictionless process.
Therefore, the
potential energy is
only relevant for
frictionless transformations.
No.
Potential energy exists.
It's a function of states.
Energy is a function of state.
And we have been able to relate
energy as a function of state
to all the other equilibrium
quantities that we
have over here.
OK?
Any questions?
OK.
So now we can answer
another side question
that I raised at
the beginning, which
is I started with xi
and Ji, as describing
the system in equilibrium.
Then I gradually
added T. I added E,
now I've added S.
How many things
do I need to describe the
system in equilibrium?
A lot of these are
dependent on each other.
And in particular
saw that mechanically
if there was the only thing
that was happening in the story,
J's could be obtained from
the derivatives of energy
with respect to x.
So J's, in some sense, once
you had E were given to you.
You didn't have to
list all of the J's.
You just needed to add
E as a function of x's.
But when you have thermal
transformations around,
that's not enough.
This equation says that if
there are n ways of doing work
on the system, there is
one of the doing heat.
You have n plus 1 independent
degrees of freedom..
So n ways of sum over i,
Ji, dxi, one way of SdT,
you have n plus one
independent variables
to describe your system.
And once you realize
that you have
a certain amount of freedom
in choosing precisely
which n plus one
you want to select.
So I could select all of
the x's and one temperature.
I could select all of
the J's and one energy.
So I have a number of choices.
And once I have made my
choice I can rearrange things
accordingly.
So suppose I had chosen
the energy in xi,
then I could write dS to
be dE over T minus sum
over i Ji over T xi.
So I just rearrange this
expression and solve for dS.
So this amounts to
my having chosen
x's and E's as independent
variables and prescribed
through this important law s
as a function of E and x's.
What about everything else?
Well, everything else you
can calculate by derivatives.
So 1 over T would be
dS by dE at constant x.
While Ji over T would be minus
dS by dxi at constant E and xJ
that is not equal to i.
OK?
Fine.
So that's sort of
kind of extract
the mathematical content that
we can get out of the second law
through this Clausius's theorem.
There is one important
corollary that
has to do be irreversible
transformations.
After all, in setting up
the Clausius's theorem
I did not say anything
about the necessity
of being in equilibrium in
order to achieve the inequality.
Reversibility allowed me
to get it as an equality.
So what can I do?
I can take any
complicated space.
I can pick a point
A and in principle,
make an irreversible
transformation to some point B.
And maybe in that
process I will get
some heat inputted
through the system dQ.
And what I would have is that
the integral going from A to B,
dQ divided by T along the path
that I have described here
which is irreversible.
But I can't say anything
about it at this point.
Clausius's theorem
has to do with cycles.
So I can, in principle connect
back from B to A reversibly.
So I go integral from B to
A, dQ reversible over T.
And having completed the
cycle I know for this cycle
that this is negative.
If I were to take this to the
other side of the equation
it becomes essentially the
difference of the entropies,
or here it's also the
difference of entropies.
But I prefer it to
be on the other side.
And then to make
these two points very
close to each other,
in which case,
I can write that dQ is
less than or equal to TdS.
This is the change in entropy
in going from A to B. OK?
Again, there's some question
here as to what this T is.
So let's get rid
of that uncertainty
by looking at processes
that are adiabatic.
So I make sure that
there is no heat
exchange in going from A to
B. What do I conclude then?
Is that for these processes
the change in entropy
has to be positive.
OK?
Because T's are generally
positive quantities.
OK?
So a consequence of
Clausius's theorem
is that entropy can only
increase in any transformation.
Its change in entropy would
be 0 for these adiabatic
transformations if you
have reversible processes.
So this is actually another
one of those statements
that you have to
think a little bit
to see whether it
has any use or not.
Because we all say that
entropy has to increase,
but is that what we
have proven here?
Not quite.
Because what we've proven is
that if you have a system that
is isolated, so there is
a system that is isolated
because I want dQ to be 0.
And I want entropy to increase.
OK?
So let's say we start with
some initial condition
and we wait and go to
some final condition
of whatever is inside the box.
I should be able to
calculate entropy
before and after in order to see
that this change is positive.
OK?
But we say entropy is
a function of state.
And what have I done here
to change this state?
I cannot calculate entropy
if the system is not
in equilibrium.
If the system is in
equilibrium it presumably
does not change as
a function of time.
So what is this
expression relevant to?
The expression is
relevant to when
you have some kind of a
constraint that you remove.
So imagine that
let's say there is
a gas in this room and some
kind of piston that is initially
clamped to some position.
Then I can calculate
the entropy of what's
on the left side, what's
on the right hand side,
and that would be
my initial entropy.
I remove the clamp.
I remove the constraint so
this can slide back and forth.
And eventually it comes
to another position.
So then I can again
calculate the final entropy
from the sum of what's
on the left side
and what's on the
right hand side.
And I can see that
entropy is increased.
So basically this
statement really
is useful when there is
some internal constraint
that you can remove.
And as you remove the
internal constraint,
the entropy increases.
So I guess that image
that we all have
is that if I give you two
pictures of a room, one
with books nicely arranged
on a shelf and one
with books randomly
distributed you
would have no problem
to time order them.
And actually presumably
there was some constraint
from the shelf that
was removed and then
these things fell down.
So that's the kind
of process for which
this statement of the
second law is appropriate.
Any questions?
OK.
So that statement is something
about approach to equilibrium.
But as I said that there was
some initial configuration
with some constraint and
as a function of removing
that constraint
the system would go
from one sort of equilibrium,
constrained equilibrium
to an unconstrained equilibrium
and this increase of entropy
tells us in which
direction it would go.
You can time order
the various processes.
Now sometimes this adiabatic
way of doing things
is not the best way.
And so depending on what it
is that you are looking at,
rather than looking
at entropy you
will be looking at
different functions.
And so the next step is to
construct different types
of functions that are
useful for telling us
something about equilibrium.
Now I'll start doing that by
some function with which you
are very familiar.
And has practically
nothing to do
with entropy and temperature.
So we are going to look
at mechanical equilibrium.
OK.
And so the kind of
prototype of this,
since we've been thinking in
terms of springs or wires,
is let's imagine that
I have a wire that
has some natural lent.
And it is sitting there
happily in equilibrium.
And then I attach, let's
say a mast to it and because
of that I'm pulling
it with a force
that I will indicate by J.
So J, if you are
in gravity, would
be mass of this times J. OK?
Now if you were doing
things in vacuum,
what would happen
to your x, which
is the distortion
that you would have
from the equilibrium
as a function of time?
What would happen is
presumably the thing
would start to oscillate and you
would get something like this.
But certainly not
equilibrium, but in real world
there is always friction
that is operating.
And so if there is
a lot of friction
what is going to
happen is that your x
will come to some final value.
So again, this is a constraint,
which I allowed this to move.
And because of that
constraint I went
from the initial equilibrium
that corresponded to x
equals to 0 to some
final equilibrium.
And you say, well, if
I want to calculate
that final equilibrium,
what I need
to do is to remove all
of the kinetic energy
so that the thing
does not move anymore,
which means that I have to
minimize the potential energy.
I'll give it the
symbol H for reasons
to become apparent shortly.
And that is the
sum of the energy
that I have in the spring.
Let's imagine that it
is a hook end spring.
We would have a formula such as
this, plus the potential energy
that I have in my
mass, which is related
to how far I go up and down.
And say an appropriate
description is minus Jx.
OK?
So this is the net potential
energy of the spring plus
whatever is supplying
the mass that
is applying in the
external force.
And so in this case, what
you have is that minimizing
H with respect to
the constraint x
will give you that the x
equilibrium is J over K. OK?
So basically it comes
down to J over K.
And that the value of this
function, potential energy
function in equilibrium
substituting this over here
is minus J squared over K. 2K.
OK?
So in many processes that
involve thermodynamics
we are going to do
essentially the same thing.
And we are going to call this
net potential central energy,
in fact, an enthalpy.
OK?
And the generalized version
of what I wrote down for you
is the following, in the
process that I described
which was related to
the increase in entropy
we were dealing with a
system that was isolated.
dQ was 0 and there was no work
because the coordinates were
not changing. dW was 0.
Whereas here, I am
looking at a process
where there is a
certain amount of work
because this external
J that I am putting
is doing work on the spring.
It is adding energy
to the spring.
And the thing is that
because of the friction
it doesn't continue
to oscillate.
So some of the energy that I
would have put in the system,
if I really were using the
formula Jidxi is lost somehow.
We can see those
oscillations have gone away.
Now I'm always doing this
process at constant J. Right?
So if I prescribe for you some
path of x as a function of T,
Jdx is the same thing as d of
Jx because J does not change.
x changes.
OK?
I'm going to also
imagine processes
where mechanical equilibrium,
but with no heat so that dQ
is 0.
If I were to add
these two together,
then I will get an
inequality involving
dE, which is less than or equal
to d of Jixi, which I can write
as the change in e minus
Jixi has to be negative.
So appropriate to
processes, which
are conducted so that
there is mechanical work
at constant force,
is this function
that is usually
called H for enthalpy.
And what we find is that the
dH is going to be negative.
And again, if you
think about it this
is precisely this
enthalpy is none other
than the potential
energy that is
in the mechanical
degrees of freedom.
And there's always
loss in the universe.
And so the direction naturally
is for this potential energy
to decrease.
One thing to note
is that dH is dE.
Thinking of it not now as a
process going on at constant J,
but as a change in
a function of state
because we said that
once I prescribe where
I am in the coordinate
space I know what, say e is.
I know what J is.
I can certainly construct a
function, which is e minus Jx.
It's another function of state.
And I can ask what happens
if I make a change from one
point in space to another point.
Along the path that potentially
allows variations in J dE
I know, is Jidxi.
And then, actually I'm
using summation conversion.
So let's remove that,
plus TdS and here
it becomes minus
Jidxi minus xidJi.
Jidxi is cancelled.
And we that if I construct
the function H as e minus Jx,
the natural variations
of it are TdS, just
like dE but rather than
Jdx I have minus xdJ.
OK?
So H is naturally expressed as
a function of variables that are
s and the Ji's.
And remember that we said we
are doing things at constant J.
So it's nice that
it happens that way.
And in particular if I
do partial derivatives
I find that my xi is minus
dH by dJi at constant s.
So that in the same
way before I said
that if you have the energy
function dE by dx will give J,
if you have the H functions,
dH by dJ would give you x.
Let's check.
Here we had an H function.
If I do a dH by dJ with a
minus sign, what do I get?
I will get J over K. What
was my equilibrium x?
It was J over K. OK?
Now both of these functions
that we have encountered so far
were expressing
the system energy
or enthalpy have as
their argument entropy.
Now if I give you a box you will
have a hard time potentially
figuring out what entropy
is, but varying temperature
is something that
we do all the time.
So it would be great if we
could start expressing things
not in terms of entropy,
in terms of anything else.
Well, what's the natural
thing if not entropy?
Here we went from x to
the conjugate variable
J. I can make a transformation
that goes from s
to the conjugate variable,
which is temperature.
And that would be
relevant, therefore,
when I'm thinking about
isothermal processes.
And so what I'm going to do is
to reverse the role of the two
elements of energy
that I had previously
for mechanical processes.
So what we had there
was that dQ was 0,
but I want dQ to be non-0.
What we had there was
that dW was non-0.
So let's figure out
processes where dW is 0,
but dQ, the same way that
previously we were doing dW
at constant J, let's do dQ
not equals to 0 at constant T.
And constant T is where the
isothermal expression comes
into play.
OK?
So if dW is 0, I have a natural
inequality that involves dQ.
I just erased it, I think.
Yeah.
It's not here.
dQ is less than or equal to TdS.
And if T is a constant
throughout the process,
I can write this as d of TS.
Add these two together
to get that dE less than
or equal to d of TS, or
taking it to the other side,
I can define a function which
is the Helmholtz free energy.
F, which is E minus TS.
And what we have is that
the natural direction
of flow for free
energy when we remove
some kind of a constraint
at constant temperature
is that we will tend to
minimize the free energy.
And then again doing
the manipulation of dF
is dE minus d of TS in general
will have minus TdS minus SdT.
The TdS part of the E will
vanish and what I will have
is Jidxi minus SdT.
So now we can see that
finally for the free energy,
the Helmholtz free energy,
and natural variable
rather than being entropy
is the temperature and all
set of displacements.
And then if you ask, well,
what happened to the entropy?
You say, well, I can get
the entropy as minus dF
by dT at constant x.
If I take this
picture of the gas
that I had put at the beginning,
which was just erased,
picture of a piston
that can slide.
And I think of that
as a box that I
bring into this room, well,
then if you'll quickly
adjust to the
temperature of the room,
as well as the
pressure of the room.
So this is going to be a
general transformation in which
both heat and the
work are exchanged.
If is at external temperature
and pressure that is fixed.
So it's a transformation that
is isothermal and constant J.
In pressure you would
call it [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
And then quite
generally you would
say extending what
we had before,
in this case dQ is, again, less
than TdS because of Clausius.
dW is less than Jdx
because you always
lose something to friction.
You always lose
something to friction.
You add the two things
together, and you
get that dE is less than or
equal to TdS, plus Jidxi.
For the transformations
that we are considering
that are at constant
t and J I can
take these expressions to
mean the same thing as d
of ts plus Jixi, which
means that more generally,
I can define a function which
is the Gibbs free energy, G,
which is the energy minus ts.
This part is the Helmholtz
free energy, minus Jixi.
And that if I regard this as
a function of state, which
certainly will be minimized
under conditions of constant J
and T for some constraint
that is removed.
Quite generally as
a state function
depending on all
of these variables,
it's variations
would be able to be
expressed as minus
SdT minus Jidxi.
ie, our G is naturally a
function of temperature
and the set of displacements.
OK.
I don't think music was
appropriate at this point.
I would have put it
earlier, but such is life.
OK.
Now there is something
that I kind of
did not pay sufficient-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Didn't you get it backwards
between the J's and the x's?
PROFESSOR: I did.
I did.
I wrote it wrong here.
So maybe that's what
the music was for.
OK.
Is it fine?
Anything else?
OK.
The thing that I wasn't
sufficiently careful with
was the list of things that
goes into mechanical work.
And one additional care
that what needs to have,
which is that suppose
I were to tell you,
let's say, the pressure
and temperature as my two
variables, and I guess this
is what I would have here
if I go and look at
pressure as my force.
Then have I told you
everything that I
need to know about the system?
So I have a box, let's
say, in this room
that is at the
pressure of this room
and at the temperature
of this room.
Have I completely
specified the box?
What have I left?
AUDIENCE: The size. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How big is it, yes.
So what I have left,
previously maybe I had volume,
but I sort of
discarded the volume
in terms of the pressure.
So what I'd really need is to
have the number of particles.
I have to specify something.
Maybe the mass,
something that has
still is going to
distinguish these boxes
in terms of their size.
Now it is most useful
to think in terms
of the number of particles.
So I give you a box and I
can say that within this box
I have so many molecules
of oxygen and nitrogen,
or whatever is the composition,
but then we sort of start
to get into the realm of
chemistry and the fact
that the different chemical
components can start
to react with each
other, maybe even
if you have a box
that is one component,
some of the molecules are going
to get absorbed on the surface.
So precisely what the
number is is potentially
something that is a variable.
And in order to specify
exactly what the energy
content of a system
is you have to specify
how many particles
and the energy
carried by those particles.
So the list of things
that appears here,
especially when you think in
terms of chemical systems,
has an additional
element that is typically
called chemical work.
And so let's separate mechanical
work from the chemical work.
So mechanical work
was sum over iJidxi
where these were
real displacements
and we can actually
write an expression that
is very similar here where
the displacements are
the number of particles
of different species,
allowing potentially there
going to other species
through chemical reactions
provided we multiply these
by some appropriate
chemical potential.
So these mu's are a
So for the reason
that I stated before
that if I were to
just-- this ambiguity
that I had about
the size of the box
tells me that I should
have at least one thing
left in my system
describing the variables
that is proportional to
the size of the system.
So typically what you
do when you construct
a Gibbs free energy is that you
subtract the mechanical work,
but you don't subtract
the chemical work.
So the ends will
remain and can tell you
how big your system is.
OK?
Now there is a conjugate way I
can certainly do the other way.
So here I constructed something
in which mechanical work was
removed, but chemical
work remained.
I could do it the
other way around.
I can define a function
that is obtained
by subtracting from the
energy the chemical work,
but leaving the mechanical
component aside.
So this function dG, OK, I
should go one step before.
So once we separate out
the contributions of Jidxi
into mechanical and
chemical components,
I would write dE as TdS
plus sum over iJidxi,
plus sum over alpha
mu alpha dN alpha.
OK?
I just explicitly separating
out those two sources of work.
Now when I constructed G,
which subtracts from e, the mu,
but not the J, what happens?
I will get a minus TdS.
This will remain unchanged.
This will get transformed
to N alpha, d mu alpha.
Just hold on a second.
So this entity that is called
the grand potential actually
completes the list of
these functions of state
that I wanted to
tell you is naturally
a function of T, the
chemical potentials
as well as the displacement.
For example, if it's a
gas the displacements
will include the
volume which tell you
how much material you have.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In that
case, do you need
to subtract an additional
TS from E and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Very good.
These are all examples
of the energies
so that you define them as
a function of temperature
rather than entropy.
The only things
that really remain,
the one function
that you sort of keep
as a function of entropy
is energy itself.
Enthalpy, too.
Yes, it has its uses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have many
questions about [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Right now I wanted to ask you
say that so a particle is added
to the system, a
particle of some species.
And this is going to change
the energy of the system.
So my question is while this
particle can bring energy
in several ways,
like kinetic energy,
or maybe it's this chemical
bound that's been broken--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: between
energy from there.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Or also
it's rest energy
from special [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So which
ones are we counting?
Which ones are we not counting?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what you see is that when
we do all of these calculations
we definitely need
to include when
we are talking about a gas,
the kinetic energy component.
The change in the covalent
bond energy definitely
has to be there if I
take an oxygen molecule
and separate it to
two oxygen atoms.
There is that change
in the energy that
has to be included
corresponding kinetic energies.
Typically the rest
mass is not included.
And so if I were to include that
it will be a shift of chemical
potential by an amount
that is mc squared.
Why do people not bother?
Because typically what we
will be trying to look at
is the change when
something happens.
And you have to bring
those particles presumably
from somewhere.
So as long as you bring in
particles from somewhere then
there's the difference
between the rest mass
that you had outside
and rest mass
that you have here, that's 0.
It's really all of
the other things that
contribute to useful quantities
that you would be involved
with like temperature, pressure.
The rest mass is irrelevant.
Now I can't rule out
that you will come up it
some process that is going on
in [INAUDIBLE] for whatever
where the rest mass is an
important contribution.
So it may, to some extent,
depend on the circumstance
that you are looking at.
But if you are asking
truly what should I
include in the
chemical potential,
it will include the rest mass.
AUDIENCE: So for example in--
I don't know, in cosmology
they often talk of
the chemical potential
of the different species,
like elementary particles
in the cosmos.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: They say that the
chemical potential of photons
is 0.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So here they have
fixed some kind convention?
PROFESSOR: No.
You see there is a
difference between photons
and other particles such as
electrons or whatever, which
is that you have value in
number or some other number
conservation that is applicable.
So any process that
you have will not
change the number
of [INAUDIBLE].
Whereas there are processes in
which there is something that
is heated and will give
you whatever number of
photons that you wish.
So there is a distinction
between things
that are conserved and things
that are not conserved.
So We will get to
that maybe later on as
to why it is appropriate to
set chemical potential to 0
for non-conserved things.
OK?
Yeah, but it's
certainly something
that we have immediately a
feel for what the pressure is
for what the
temperature is, so we
have our senses seem
to sort of tell you
the reality of
temperature and pressure,
but maybe not so much
the chemical potential.
So I tried to see whether we
have a sense that actually
is sensitive to
chemical potential
and we do to some extent.
As you drink
something and you say
it's too salty, or
whatever, so somehow you
are measuring the chemical
potential of sort.
So if you like that, that would
be your sensual equivalent
of chemical potential.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a potential where
you have both chemical
and mechanical work?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that will run
into the problem
of if I do that,
then my parameter is
going to be T, J, and mu.
And then I can ask you,
how much do I have?
Because all of these
quantities are intensive.
Right?
So it could be a box this
is one cubic centimeters
or miles long.
So I am not allowed to do that.
And there is a mathematical
reason for that
that I was going
to come to shortly.
Other questions?
OK.
So We are going to
take an interlude.
Actually, the last question
is quite relevant to what
we are going to do next,
which is that we have
these functions defined,
many coordinates,
and one of the things that
thermodynamics allows you to do
is to relate measurements
of one set of quantities,
another set of quantities.
And it does so
through developing
mathematical
relationships that you
can have between these
different functions of state.
So the next segment has to
do with mathematical results,
which I will subdivide into
two sets of statements.
One set of statement
follow from the discussion
that we have had so far, which
has to do with extensivity.
What do I mean?
Let's take a look at our most
fundamental expression, which
is dE is TdS plus
sum over iJdxi,
plus sum over alpha
mu alpha dN alpha.
Now you recognize that certainly
as the amount of material
gets increased, the number
of particles increases.
The typical sizes and
displacements get bigger.
The energy content gets bigger.
The entropy content is
related to the heat content
and so that gets bigger.
So these differential forms
that I have on this expression,
they're all proportional
to the size of the system.
What does that mean?
It means that e, the
way that I have it
here has as its natural
variables S, x, N.
And extensivity means that if I
were to make my system twice as
large, so that all
of these quantities
would get multiplied
by a factor of two,
the energy content would get
multiplied by a factor of two.
OK?
Now it is important to state
that this is not a requirement.
OK?
This is a statement
about most things
that we encounter around
us, but once you go,
let's say, to the cosmos,
and you have a star,
the gravitational
energy of the star
is not proportional
to its volume.
It goes the size to
some fractional power.
So that is an example of a
system because of the way
gravity works as a
long range force, that
is not extensive system.
Typically this
would work as long
as you have interactions
among your elements
that are sufficiently
short-ranged
so that you don't
get non-extensivity.
If that's the case then
I can take a derivative
of this expression with respect
to lambda, evaluated at lambda
equals 2, 1.
If I take a derivative
with respect to lambda
here I will have dE by
dS, times S. I mean,
the argument here
is lambda S. I am
taking a derivative with
respect to the first argument.
So I bring out a factor of
S. dE by dS at constant x
and N. And then the next
term is xi dE with respect
to all the different
xi's at constant S and N.
Next one is going to be
N alpha, dE by dN alpha
at constant x and S. And
there's only one lambda
on this side, which is
going to give me E of Sx.
OK?
Now if I look at my
initial expression
I can immediately see that
dE by dS at constant x
and N is none other
than T. So this
is the same thing as T.
dE by dxi at constant s
and n is none other than Ji.
dE by dN alpha at constant x and
Js is none other than mu alpha.
So once I set the argument to be
1, so that all of these things
are evaluated at
lambda equals to 1,
I have the result that e is
equal to TS plus Jixi, plus mu
alpha N alpha.
So in some sense all I did was
I took the more fundamental
expression and removed
all of the d's.
So some places, this is called
the fundamental relation,
but I don't like that because it
is only valued for systems that
are extensive, whereas
the initial formula
is valued irrespective of that.
OK?
Now once I have
this what I can do
is I can think of
this as a relationship
among different
functions of state.
Take a derivative and
write it as dE is d of TS.
D of TS is TdS plus SdT, plus
d of Jixi, which gives me
Jidxi plus xidJi,
plus d of mu alpha.
And alpha will give
me mu alpha dn alpha,
plus N alpha d mu alpha.
OK?
This is just a rewriting
of this expression
in differential form.
But I know that dE is the
same thing as TdS plus Jdx
plus mu n alpha.
So immediately what it tells me
is that the intensive variables
T, J, and mu our constrained
to satisfy this relation, which
is called a
Gibbs-Duhem relation.
OK?
So this is, if you like,
the mathematical reason
for my answer before.
That I cannot choose this set of
variables to describe my system
because this set of variables
are not independent.
If I vary two of them the
variation of the other one
is fixed.
And I said I need N plus 1
independent degrees of freedom.
If I choose all of
the intensive ones
I'm really using one additional
relationship that relates them,
makes them dependent.
And of course this
also goes to the fact
that I won't know what the size
of the system is, both of them
reflections of extensivity.
Just as an example, let's see.
Chemical potential
along isotherm.
So for a gas, what would I have?
I would write SdT minus Vdp.
That is my contribution from
the work here remembering
that hydrostatic work
at the wrong side.
And then I have N
d mu equals to 0.
I said how do these
vary along an isotherm?
Isotherm means that I have
to set dT equals to 0.
If I'm along an isotherm
then I have that d mu
is rearranging
things a little bit.
Mu over NdP.
So this is the formula
that I will have to use.
Now let's specialize to
the case of an ideal gas.
So I'm going to use
here an ideal gas.
For the case of the ideal
gas we had the relationship
that PV was NKT.
So v over n is the same
thing as kT over p.
Remember that we are
dealing with an isotherm,
so T is constant.
dp over pi can
integrate, and therefore
conclude that mu at a
constant along an isotherm,
as a function of the other two
intensive variables T and P,
is some reference that comes
from a constant of integration.
And then I have KT,
integral of dP over P
is log of P divided by sum.
Actually, I already
put the constant.
OK?
Very briefly to be
expanded upon next lecture,
the other set of
mathematical relations
go under the name of
Maxwell relations.
And they follow from the
following observation.
If I have a function of
more than one variable,
let's say, f of x and y, two
variables, then the natural way
to write this
consistent with what
we had before is that df is df
by dx partial at constant ydx,
plus dfy, the y
at constant x dy.
But one thing that
we know from calculus
is that these are
first derivatives,
and there are a bunch
of second derivatives.
In particular, the second
derivative d2 f, dx, dy
is independent of the order
of taking the derivatives.
Which means that if I take
a derivative of this object
with respect to y, I
will get the same thing
if I were to take a derivative
of the second object
with respect to x.
So in particular if I go back
to my fundamental equation,
dE, let's forget about
the chemical potential
because time is running
short, Jidxi plus TdS.
I identify T and Ji as
the first derivatives.
That is, Ji is the
first derivative of e
with respect to xi
at constant S. T
is the first derivative
of E, with respect
to S at constant x.
Then if I were to take a second
derivative to construct d2E
with respect to x and T, and
S, I could do it two ways.
I already have a derivative with
respect to x that gave me Ji,
so I take another
derivative of J
with respect to S,
now at constant x.
Or I can take a
derivative here, which
is dT by dxi at constant
S. And depending
on which one of the many
functions of state that we
introduced, E, F, G,
H, you can certainly
make corresponding second
derivative inequalities.
And the key to sort of
understanding all of them
is this equality of
second derivatives.
So what I will start
next time around
is to just give you a set
of things on the left hand
side, the analog of this.
So for example, I could
choose dS by dxi at constant T
and show that just by
looking at the form of this
how we will be able to construct
what this thing is related
through a Maxwell construction.
OK?
Thank you.